Остання подорож екс-канцлера ФРН Гельмута Коля -
з родинного бунгало в Людвіґсгафені.
Тут 16 червня він помер у віці 87 років.
Труну перевезуть до французького Страсбурга,
де у Європарламенті відбудеться європейський
державний акт прощання з померлим.
Така церемонія відбудеться уперше.
Чому, власне?
Насамперед - щоб віддати належне заслугам Коля у єднанні континенту.
Ідею запропонував президент Єврокомісії Жан-Клод Юнкер.
По-друге, за бажанням вдови покійного
німецького державного акту не буде.
Коль ображався на багатьох німецьких політиків.
Також удова не хотіла, аби на жалобних церемоніях виступила
канцлерка Меркель –
знову ж таки через давні образи.
Втім, відмова від державної панихиди,
або, як дехто називає, "посмертна помста Коля"
викликала нерозуміння серед громадськості Німеччини.
"Він був визначним європейцем.
Отже, він вартий європейського державного акту.
Але мало би відбутися і гідне державне поховання у Німеччині."
"Те, що коїться у його родинному колі - сумно.
Це не має виходити на громадське обговорення".
"Якщо він справді так хотів, тоді гаразд."
"Європейський державний акт –
це вищий рівень, ніж німецький".
Утім, заповіт Коля не мав впливу на канцлерку.
Анґела Меркель збирається виступити
на жалобній церемонії у Європарламенті.
Гості з Європи та усього світу,
зокрема й Білл Клінтон,
віддадуть останню шану архітектору
німецького та європейського єднання.
Після цього труну на гелікоптері доправлять на батьківщину Коля у Німеччині,
завантажать на корабель і у супроводі цілої флотилії по Рейну
перевезуть до собору міста Шпаєр.
Саме в цьому храмі –
в улюбленому храмі Коля –
громадяни зможуть попрощатися з екс-канцлером –
на церемонії з військовими почестями.
І, згідно із заповітом, поряд відбудеться поховання.